this is the week that all the partners  are switching up with all the dancers  makes for some very interesting pairs  and vowels partners frontrunner bindi  Irwin but no matter who bindi is Dancing  with the boyfriend they're doing the  cha-cha tonight and we're guessing bindi  will have her usual support system in  the audience mom and her brother she's  even had her boyfriend there u.s.  wakeboarder Chandler Powell bindi told  us how they make their long-distance  relationship work I am one of those  old-fashioned people and I love to write  so I write a lot yeah diverse letters  saves the world  bindis keeping the team krikey name for  tonight but they'll be facing a tough  critic Val's brother Max is a guest  judge I could never be a judge because I  would just be like you all good ten and  I'm gonna hook you all and sorry that  would kind of fail but he will be so  brilliant because he will bring  something new and different to the  judging arena